la Parole de Dieu elle est de tendre la
main à l'autre mais pas pour le faire
changer
pas pour le faire changer pour le
comprendre
[Applaudissements]
j'espère qu'il se souvient pas de moi
c'était de mon temps de mannequin qui
doit dire cinq ou six ans j'étais du
côté du Théâtre des Variétés dans le
métro et je vous ai croisé dans le métro
et je me suis fait toute petite même pas
retournéyam
vous connaissez linda Hardy Laurent
Baffie Anthony Kavanagh Christine Boutin
et l'âme voilà non là vous connaissez
pas
ou qu'ils aillent
[Musique]
sont tristes à la fête ils sont seuls
dans leur tête c'est la phrase qui vous
a tout de suite quand vous avez pas
c'est pas normal
il est au théâtre c'est pas normal ceux
qui travaillent beaucoup
je vous ai vu à célébrité lundi soir sur
TF1 je tiens un peu tard
en revanche vous étiez très bien c'est
Drucker dimanche là
l'homosexualité c'est vous a choqué non
mais Bruno Masure a manqué de
délicatesse
pas du tout pas du tout à propos il
demande à Francis Huster est-ce que vous
avez attendu deux ans pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez attendu deux ans pour
vivre avec votre femme est-ce que c'est
parce que vous êtes nié ou homosexuel
alors moi je suis une femme je suis
désolé je défends français super c'est
pas parce que un homme ne décide pas
vivre avec vous au bout de deux ans que
qu'il est lié ou homosexuel
je regarde l'émission depuis le début
celle-là
et
je trouve madame très intelligente elle
répond très finement aux questions elle
est venue ici pour être très sympathique
pour la connaisse telle qu'elle est j'ai
lu son livre il y a des passages qui
m'ont très intéressé notamment un
passage sur la défense de la langue
française et je vous félicite parce que
vous dites des choses tout à fait
pertinentes c'est pas une histoire de
gauche ou droite c'est une histoire
qu'on se fout de la gueule du monde
puisqu'on défend pas le français au plus
haut niveau comme on doit le défendre et
je vous félicite pour ça vous dites
aussi que vous avez toujours dans la
poche le verset 123 si je ne m'abuse
qui prête à supporter les humiliations
de la vie
et je trouve que vous êtes parfaitement
réussi cette émission en plus à l'image
vous êtes sympathique vous êtes sympa
vous n'êtes pas du tout fermé vous avez
même vous avez un comment une espèce de
vérité de fond vous avez de l'humour et
tout mais je suis heureux d'être là pour
vous dire à quel point votre attitude
m'a choqué pour deux choses la première
sur le fond je supporte pas qu'on dise
du mal des homosexuels parce qu'on a
l'air et surtout l'interview du poète
qui est venu tout à l'heure et qui a
vraiment de la qui a vraiment une arme
et tout qui avait un peu de trac et tout
mais je trouve que c'est rendre un très
mauvais service il a pas besoin de
perruque à la con il a pas besoin de de
trucs bidon parce que c'est aller tout à
fait dans le sens de faire croire que
les homosexuels sont des gens à part les
Juifs sont à part les déguns sont à part
les noirs sont à part les Arabes sont à
part et la France et les Français
ce que je veux dire simplement ce que je
veux dire c'est que vous pouvez pas d'un
côté avoir la générosité qui est mal de
vous dans cette émission et en même
temps continuer persuadé d'avoir raison
sur tout je veux dire comprenez-moi bien
ce qui m'a choqué énormément d'abord
c'est que vous avez toujours
l'impression de croire que et vous dites
que vous êtes catholique vous avez
toujours l'impression de croire que la
vérité appartient à une partie c'est
faux la vérité elle n'est que partager
c'est le mensonge qui appartient à une
partie et je voudrais vous rappeler que
Dieu est juif son fils est juif non mais
je vous explique le cheminement son fils
est juif et ce fils juif le Christ s'est
révolté pour essayer de donner une autre
parole mais de la même façon qu'on est
basé sur une civilisation
judéo-chrétienne nous avons en France
des musulmans alors eux aussi sont
français quel que soit leur couleur non
non mais je vais vous dire en face
attendez ce matin
excusez-moi comme toutes les spectateurs
je voudrais passer du côté du poste et
venir ici juste une seconde pour vous
dire que je voudrais que vous oeuvre de
compassion et vous dire que la Parole de
Dieu qu'elle soit juive chrétienne
musulmane islamiste de quelle que soit
le bord bouddhiste autour la Parole de
Dieu elle est de tendre la main à
l'autre mais pas pour le faire changer
bien sûr pas pour le faire changer pour
le comprendre et ce qui m'a beaucoup
gêné dans l'émission c'est qu'une fois
de plus on amalgame l'homosexualité à
une déviation sexuelle une fois de plus
on fait croire
c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça que
j'avais répondu et c'est pour ça non non
et c'est pour ça attendez attendez c'est
pour ça c'est pour ça je parle pas de
vous personnellement je pour vous Madame
je dis simplement que vous avez votre
livre le montre beaucoup de qualité mais
vous avez aussi derrière un état
d'esprit un pas nouveau à faire pour
comprendre la société dont vous parlez
et surtout de la comprendre de façon
positive vous craignez l'Europe vous
craignez la déviation c'est ce que vous
avez mis dans votre vous en méfiez vous
en méfiez et je dois vous dire si je
dois vous dire je dois vous dire pour
finir donc sur vraiment du côté tout à
fait positif que vous avez donc très
bien connu Raymond Barre il y a eu une
bombe qui a sauté rue Copernic
Monsieur Raymond Barre la femme de
Monsieur Raymond Barre est juive
monsieur ray-bombard n'a jamais été
antisémite or il s'est trouvé que les
journalistes lui ont demandé à la sortie
Griezmann le Premier ministre et tout et
qu'il a dit oui il y a eu les victimes
et tout et puis les pauvres victimes
innocentes qui passaient dans la rue
comme si ceux qui étaient à la synagogue
n'étaient pas innocente c'est pour ça
que je veux vous dire que et je respecte
beaucoup Raymond Barre pour 50 vraiment
profondément comme homme pour son
courage et pour et pour beaucoup
d'initiatives qu'il a fait je dois vous
dire qu'il faut absolument que vous les
hommes politiques vous vous poignet
vraiment maintenant pas seulement dans
ces émissions mais de votre vie tous les
jours un langage beaucoup plus ouvert et
surtout pas d'informer par des
certitudes des prises de position qui ne
peuvent pas convaincre les jeunes
maintenant la fin la question c'est que
je pense que au point de vue
homosexuel ce qui m'avait tout
simplement gêné c'est l'amalgame dans la
question entre est-ce que vous êtes nié
ou homosexuel c'est tout c'est-à-dire
faire croire que l'homosexualité c'est
d'être nier et puis attendez juste un
truc je t'assure Thierry c'est une
seconde c'est pour vous dire aussi
simplement que justement ce qui me
réjouit dans votre attitude vous parlez
d'amour c'est que avant tout la parole
du Christ des Juifs n'importe quelle
religion c'est l'amour et que pour moi
être homosexuel je ne suis pas mais si
je l'avais été c'était surtout et mais
l'autre et mais l'autre c'est l'amour
merci princesse
[Applaudissements]
pas cette compassion cette charité
chrétienne que vous avez en vous parce
que vous êtes très croyante et à la fois
ces certitudes qui sont quand même très
sectaires je ne sais pas si je me ferais
bien comprendre je ne sais pas si les
mots que je vais prendre seront compris
mais parce que il y a une très grande
différence pour moi entre le péché et le
pêcheur je ne pardonne jamais le péché
mais je pardonne toujours au pêcheur
c'est pour ça que vous dites les
personnes homosexuelles parce que pour
vous absolument on est d'abord une
personne
personnaliste c'est certainement c'est
pas bien c'est l'homosexualité qui n'est
pas acceptable qui n'est pas acceptable
l'homosexuel mais pas l'homosexualité
absolument pas dire ça un chrétien ne
peut pas dire ça écoutez je vais vous
répondre tout simplement vous connaissez
le tableau de la scène et ce que vous
pensez que sur cet tableau il y a pas un
homosexuel peut-être alors on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas dire ça il faut
arrêter parce qu'à ce moment-là on va
faire un sujet Comment expliquer vous
dans votre livre par exemple que vous
parlez des difficultés profondes de
pouvoir à propos de l'argent d'aider
et comment vous pouvez penser qu'au
Vatican on croule sous les milliards
comment vous pouvez penser laissez-moi
parler laissez-moi parler laissez-moi
parler laissez-moi parler j'ai été en
tournée dans un pays qui s'appelle Haïti
j'étais dans la ville à Port-au-Prince
je voyais des gens qui crevaient de faim
qui crevaient de faim qui était par
terre qui se traînait et je voyais
passer dans des Mercedes et dans des
grandes voitures des hommes de religion
qui allaient dans les petits villages
avec les cases chercher ce qui gagnait
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire si vous
voulez bon cette émission est agréable
j'ai suis venu avec plaisir mais là
franchement ça prend une tournure qui
n'est pas acceptable je vous le dis
franchement parce que ce sont parce que
ce sont des des caricatures qui sont
dites je suis désolé les Francis Huster
je vous respecte beaucoup vous êtes un
acteur et un homme de talent mais
franchement la diatrie que vous venez de
l'ancienne n'est pas acceptable quand
vous me parlez de la pauvreté en Haïti
naturellement que je la déplore moi je
ne suis pas allé en Haïti mais je suis
allée en Équateur je suis allée en
Amérique du Sud et j'ai vu la véritable
pauvreté mais vous vous avez un Francis
Huster il y a aussi chez nous en France
des gens qui connaissent vraiment la
misère et qui ne sont pas du tout
intégrés dans notre société parce que
nous faisons tout pour qu'ils ne le soit
pas nous tous nous tous naturellement le
responsable politique mais vous comme
les jeunes comme les moins jeunes tout
le monde parce que personne ne veut se
remettre en cause et il y a dans notre
pays des gens qui n'ont pas droit à la
parole et moi je dis que déjà
c'est de faire vous voyez ce que ça veut
dire
vous vous exprimez très bien vous
défendez très bien votre point de vue
donc ça veut dire que vous êtes bien
pour le partage bien sûr ben écoutez je
l'ai lu je l'ai écrit
vous avez bien pour le partage mais le
partage pas seulement le partage des
richesses le partage non mais le partage
moral alors reprise donc de duo pour
violoncer
mais vraiment je te promets non je te
promets 45 secondes non la seule chose
qui m'a qui m'a gêné mais c'est pour ça
que je voulais juste vous poser la
question j'ai complètement oublié
pourquoi moi
vous vous avez fondu en larmes c'est à
dire que je pense qu'un homme politique
je dis homme politique par le jardin je
veux dire ne doit absolument pas être
sensible sur ce qu'on lui fait et je
trouve que dans chacun sa position la
mienne est différente de la vôtre mais
peu importe on s'en fout je suis pas un
homme politique mais simplement ce qui
m'a choqué je me suis dit mais pourquoi
cette femme pleure alors elle fait un
cas personnel de des attaques qu'on lui
fait c'est comme si un chirurgien
pendant une opération pleurait de ce qui
se passe c'est tout c'est la seule chose
parce que je suis comme vous faites de
chair et d'os et que les paroles de
Monsieur Jospin m'ont profondément
blessé c'est une affaire dans l'état ça
n'est pas une affaire d'État
Thierry j'aurais juste dire un truc ça
vous dérange pas non ça vous dérange pas
que vous parliez non moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on tourne cette table et
c'est vrai que depuis la nuit des temps
c'est toujours existé il y a toujours eu
des homosexuels et j'aimerais qu'on en
arrête avec chacun la liberté égalité
fraternité quoi je veux dire chaque on
est né sur le nez homosexuel et ben on
le laisse tranquille et puis je veux
dire c'est faut arrêter avec tout ça
quoi je cherche un fait sa vie
à la mairie c'est ça le truc je ne pense
pas qu'il soit bon pour la société
française qui vient un mariage les
homosexuels on va parfaire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu